[Musique]
l'écart ça me sont déjà comparé aux amis
et sa famille virons les autres de la
vie si tous kankan est astucieux mais
le plus sérieux est qu'à sa vie à jouer
il suffit de vouloir devenir ami fabrice
jau y suit un volatile migy plein
d'idées dans c'est vrai un bon et tué un
beau volatile oui oui on joue au jeu du
pays aux jeux de la géographie la
géographie d'accord 1
alors toujours trois éléments toujours
trois éléments le premier le second le
3e bien joaillier la forme du pays le
oui bon le drapeau et le troisième
bonjour dans la langue du pays
le tout son sens en histoire n 1 le tout
sur ce tableau sur ce tableau il ya
fleure bon tu découvres le premier
élément le contour du pays le contour du
pays
à gauche du tableau c'est plus difficile
que la semaine dernière à je te préviens
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe via tu vois oui
c'est pas commode en bas tout de même
regarde c'est un pays assez
caractéristique vois ça je suis dans mes
petits souliers quand je vois ça ah bon
l'autre élément
oui le drapeau de ce pays le drapeau de
ce pays le voilà le matin pour ceux qui
n'ont pas la couleur
il s'agit là du verre du blanc et du
rouge
alors maintenant bonjour dans la langue
de ce pays
bonjour dans la langue du pays ries
buongiorno ben johnson
we are back s'apprête à l'imagination
écoute je crois quand même que tous nos
amis savent très bien que l'un de nos
voisins à cette forme de la botte
1 ça ressemble à une botte ça c'est
l'italie tout simplement ni reçues plus
d'une loi dans les plumes à brigitte si
ce n'est pas une chance alors voilà
l'italie voilà son drapeau et banjo qui
veut dire bonjour voila tu pars forme à
des efforts a le droit d'aller dans le
jardin j'y vais dans le jardin c'est
l'été c'est les vacances alors vas
t'amuser et bajaur en profitait
absolument stade à nous on prépare le
jeu du point commun du caca oui tiens au
courant bien 10,2 quoi oui bien sûr
toujours on l'appelle
gilles fabry oui bah bien j'arrive à 100
mg arrive haussier bonjour rapide aux
bons jours il c'est moi je reviens oui
howe qui m'énerve fille elle est tout le
temps derrière tes bottes bah oui chez
pai ne perdons pas tôt le point commun
alors je rappelle tout de même si vous
le voulez bien que le point commun est
un point commun vous avez entre vous oui
mais tous je veux dire ce que vous êtes
allons retrouver tous ensemble
quel est le point commun alors marché
commence avec encore oui alors bon chez
moi il ya des gens très sérieux qui se
rassemble ils sont très sérieux et très
nombreux d'ailleurs ils viennent de
toutes les régions de france ils
viennent discuter de problèmes très
importants ils viennent même parler de
ce qu'on va apprendre en classe 27 dire
si c'est sérieux c'est drôle d'ailleurs
car quand on les voit tous ces gens on
dirait qu'ils sont en classe ils sont
derrière leur pupitre ils ont des
cahiers des stylos tout ça ils prennent
des notes et bien quelquefois y crie
très fort mais très fort et qu'alors
qu'il ya un surveillant qui les attrape
voilà qui leur dit de sauter voilà je la
trouvais déjà un petit bah non c'est pas
facile là j'attends un petit peu je veux
savoir ce que bell bell oui moi ont pu
me trouver dans un appartement on me
trouve même dans tous les appartements
c'est un endroit que j'aime beaucoup et
dans lequel je passe une bonne partie de
mon existence chacun de nous possède un
endroit de ce genre
j'ai fait peindre le mien dans des
couleurs très claires j'ai placé des
tableaux des photos qui me rappelle des
bons souvenirs
cet endroit est fait pour le repos il
doit être éloigné du bruit en amour il
faut qu'il soit nous y est tu vois ce
que je crois que je commence à avoir une
idée ou smooth une rumba moi moi tu sais
je je ne suis pas aussi élégant que ce
que je viens de décrire belle bella non
non non non non non je suis bien plus
modeste oui mais je suis très utile pour
certaines personnes mais je rappelle aux
automobilistes en particulier seulement
pour que je puisse leur rendre service
pour que je leur permettent de rouler il
me faut de l'air harrison si j'ai pas
d'air ça là je ne suis qu'une pauvre
chose alors sans former et sans valeur
mais l'heure des comptes donne de l'air
alors à moi à moi les cyclistes à moi
les motocyclistes les automobilistes je
vais leur faire dévorer des kilomètres à
cuba oui je crois que ça y est cette
fois ci il me semble bien que je
trouvais le point commun qui vous unit
tous donc en principe tout cancan
d'après la description devait devrait
être la chambre des députés
n'est ce pas la chambre des députés
on l'appelle aujourd'hui l'assemblée
nationale doit que chambre simplement
d'un appartement oui en simple vous si
oui c'est une chambre à air sombre et
voilà labadie d'or
alors il faut me donne cette forme est
là quelle belle tu sais que tu dois
travailler maintenant ici c'est très
très intéressant jouer ou non
pourquoi non pas lorsque rapido s'il te
plait je te remercie si tu permets qu'on
continue à des choses à faire moi ah les
belles fabrice je ne laisse puisque je
vais aller préparer notre petit jeu
musical bon troisième podium grâce à
leurs bons au revoir bon alors c'est dix
mois pousse moussu ll oui j'ai
l'impression que c'est à tous bah oui ça
va être à nous alors tu sais ce qui se
passe d'habitude le rite au graff de
faire attention et ben je te demande de
faire attention les hivers tu es prêt
oui je suis prêt bon me proposes tu es
bien écoute je ne sais pas si ton
tableau va être assez large parce que
bon c'est un mot en onze lettres on
pense qu'ils commencent par qui commence
par un n 1 n
j'ai bien sûr de toi oui un aimant après
je fais alors tu fais notre titre et oui
comme d'habitude 1-2-3-4 bien 5 6 7 8 9
dernières lettres 1n accord encore hui
encore allen est maintenant à toi je
t'écoute
est ce que c'est une fleur à no no no -
est-ce que c'est un arbre non non plus
alors c'est un animal oui c'est un
animal parce que ça ce sont les trois
sujets qu'il adore
voilà bon un anime un gros animal oui je
sais enfin moyens gay et bien que tu as
et les plus grands que moi oui oh bah ça
je pas difficile alors ce monsieur est
ce que c'est un animal que nous trouvons
dans les forêts françaises par exemple
non non non non non non ne n'y en a pas
en france mon nom en retrait peut
vraiment rêver je peux te dire qu'il a
quatre pattes
il a quatre pas puis la cata et l'est
pas il vit pas en france
n'habite pas en phr est ce que c'est un
animal qui rampe
oh non non ils rendent pas non est ce
que c'est un animal qui sautent a de
temps en temps entre frissons qu'il est
ce qu'il peut courir
ah oui tu veux que je te donne la
troisième lettre
enfin j'aimerais bien faire pour un td
oui oui la troisième lettre cette 1ère
1er mai avec la troisième lettre riz la
troisième est qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
être que ça est-ce que c'est est ce que
c'est un animal qui qui a des poils au
oui oui l'année poil oui oh oui est ce
que c'est un animal qui existent en
afrique
oui oui oui 9 non mais c'est bien puis c
est ce qu il a des mains oui là oui oui
là deux pattes et phi phi des mains
c'est pas un sage oui si pas trouvé
c'est un sage si c'est un singe heures
passées bon il pourrait y avoir quoi
c'est pas possible tu n'aurais pas fait
une chose pareille
c'est pas un orang outan ainsi un orang
outan comment un orang outan bt créé un
orang outan avec un et la wii avec un n
1 devront bah oui enfin pouces moussu
c'est la liaison c'est un orang outan
chez la liaison moi je vais te ça
s'écrit comme lui les propos ça s'écrit
comme ça oran comme ça en est et puis en
plus tu m'aurais pu me dire que j'avais
un trait d'union et il y as après ou
temps tu es à elle un orang outan est
coûteuse et pas autre chose
c'est pas croyab et pas de changer pas
de choses parce que moi j'étais bien
content d'avoir appris qu'on ne mettait
pas de jets à la fin alors
bah oui mais au dénommé pas 1 m oui mais
moi je croyais que tu allais me
féliciter et puis voilà craque je me
fais encore attraper ben tant pis pour
toi puisque c'est comme ça je te
laisserai pas parlé on s'est tous war
très belles belles tout de suite s'est
disputée en la lier deux ans qu'on va
retrouver la patrie j'avais quoi
la cia musique plus tard le soir
[Musique]
ah sacrée belle belle takis oui je veux
bien que nous jouions à notre petit jeu
des notes de musique mais je te préviens
je suis une merde mais énervé quand ça
se fait ça je suis au travail style
bâtir une birmanie
ni que je vaux bien là je crois qu'il a
eu l'indre on joue tout de suite alors
eh oui qu'il connaît l'autre j'ai alors
moi je vais te dire une chose si tu me
parles de cylindres je mettrais ainsi
parce qu'avec un être si nous avons les
voitures à six cylindres et tia koné des
choses tu sais mon batteur oui et puis
c'est moderne il est confortable cette
voiture elle possède des sièges
réglables
mais quoi dix années en fait il y en a
comme titre
tout ça avant je vois tu trouves cette
note de musique ça fait liban siège suit
les dossiers mais bien sûr des danses il
est réglable grâce au moteur qu il est
très lent cieux alors bon silencieux wee
les troubles en syrie
si tu sais je ne sais pas exactement à
quoi ça sert mais là des espaces de pub
à iode
tu veux parler des des farios éclairé
des phares ailleurs oui et puis on est
bien dedans
le chauffage il y eut un système à ses
yeux tu lui dis aux huttes joli petit
trouve le ci devant le style on le met
va c'est pas grave système si la laine
vissé peep-toe ici il y à un élu me to
gars tu dois pas t'en servir beaucoup
hein
non parce que je ne fume pas il a bien
raison d'en trouver oui ces gars 1 à lui
à ses gars oui oui oui et on m'a dit
aussi qu'il y avait
j'ai pas trouvé exactement et un truc
qui s'appelle inventis twitter et
bonjour si la terre a encore toi là tu
viens nous déranger alors que d autres a
dû jouer en double et a produit tu sais
qu'elle sera avec silva tir on me
remarque que je vais fermer comme
punition
t c'est quoi des commissions des
communautés si on me voit là mais il
faut quand même que je passe mon nom
attends je recommence
oui oh que je passe mon père abattant
j'avais fait tomber notre ça tombe bien
dans ton permis si ça exhalant des
leaders étaient pas dedans il est très
mignon
il est quoi il est prêt je laisse alors
très mignon encore amusé à la voici fini
et bah c'est très bien luccioni bas chez
panda on va écouter ce que ça donne
parce qu'on a fait une petite mélodie là
alors nous avons ici dont 6
kwassa kwassa à ça c'est
merveilleusement laisse george avant
d'être chassés
alan très bien y avait moi chanter notre
chanson l'étape ça me sont déjà qu'on
peut pas les amis les cas ça vous diront
que la vie majel les désistements et les
shops des choses mais comme juni pas de
mine war il faudra faire attention les
cas ça me sort par pendaison jeudi 24
ça me sont heureux paris c'est ma vie
oui
un jour cela
[Musique]
ici je vouloir revenir à jamie hince et
si je vouloir devenir amis
oui
[Musique]
c'est une question